[Musique]
c'est une femme également qui est avec
nous ce matin elle va se présenter tout
d'abord votre profession
député votre situation familiale
mariée et mère de trois enfants vous
avez une obsession dans la vie
oui toujours bien faire et une devise
être vaut mieux qu'à voir votre prénom
et votre nom valérie pécresse vous venez
me rejoindre
valérie pécresse est avec nous elle est
député de l'ump elle est secrétaire
général aussi délégué de l'ump merci
d'être là vous savez que dans l'émission
on aime bien en faire comprendre la
personnalité de nos invités alors on va
égrainé des souvenirs on va égrener
votre parcours on démarre toujours
évidemment par l'enfance m 1,14 me
laissait pas de train non c'est pas
neutre ça donne un amour de la france
profonde alors évidemment quand on est
petit on croit toujours que le feu
d'artifice et pour vous pour votre
anniversaire jusqu'au moment où on se
rend compte que bon peut-être peut-être
ça a une signification plus grande mais
c'est vrai que du coup depuis les
défilés militaires me font pleurer quand
vous repensez à votre enfance est-ce
qu'il ya quelque chose de particulier
qui vient comme ça en bon rang gains
sans réfléchir mais j'ai eu une enfance
assez solitaire parce que j'étais
l'aînée de très loin mes parents et mon
frère beaucoup plus tard que moi et donc
et donc j'étais l'aînée j'étais donc
assez solitaire et alors tous mes petits
cousins j'avais l'habitude de leur faire
jouer des pièces de théâtre j'écrivais
des pièces de théâtre et je leur monter
des pièces de théâtre et voilà je vous
avais toujours et le spectacle oui oui à
l'époque je rêvais d'être actrice et
puis je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
pas le talent alors je me suis orienté
vers la besoin de savoir
si si si si si j'ai essayé d'être
amateur mais j'étais pas assez je lui il
y avait beaucoup de petits beaucoup plus
jolie pour jouer déjà deux premières pas
que des premières
non c'est vrai c'est vrai il ya aussi
les servantes
donc pas inquiet
vous êtes issu quand même d'une famille
plutôt bourgeoise est ce que vous aviez
conscience d'être issu d'un milieu
privilégié j'avais surtout conscience
d'être issu d'un milieu très
intellectuel parce qu'en réalité mon
j'ai grandi dans la banlieue ouest avec
des familles qui elles étaient des
familles d'industriels d'hommes
d'affaires et qui elle était
effectivement plus aisés et nous on
était fier de du savoir fier d'avoir
fait des études mon grand père était
médecin mon père était professeur
lui-même était d'une famille de
commerçants des hautes-alpes donc
vraiment huitième enfant donc vraiment
il s'était fait tout seul par l'étude
donc cette notion de l'étude du savoir
de la richesse que c'est de posséder le
savoir c'était vraiment très important à
la maison c'est intéressant parce que
vous venez de parler de votre père de
votre grand-père et vous parlez beaucoup
plus rarement de votre mère pourquoi
peut-être parce qu'on aimait rail
relation totalement fusionnelle et quand
on a une relation totalement fusionnelle
on n'en parle pas voilà je crois que je
compte énormément sur ma mère et et elle
le sait et du coup voilà qui est plus
difficile d'en parler ll maternelle ou
auprès de vous où elle a un rôle de
complice de soutien elle est beaucoup
plus est les maternelles c'est vraiment
mais c'est vraiment mon soutien c'est
elle qui m'a qui m'a aidé c'est elle qui
m'a porté dans les moments difficiles
vous dites c'est amusant d'ailleurs
parce que c'est un qualificatif qu'on
entend pas souvent dans votre bouche
vous étiez red dawn de votre grand père
oui oui j'étais fasciné par mon grand
père parce que d'abord parce que c'était
un homme fascinant c'était un médecin de
l'âme cette soutien et donc ils avaient
aussi à l'aise de la dépression voilà
spécialiste de la dépression et est l'un
des premiers qui a dit en réalité tous
que la dépression était une maladie et
ça s'était très nouveau à l'époque si à
l'époque on disait prends sur toi
va va prendre l'air à air toi on disait
léon disaient les travailleurs manuels
n'ont pas de dépression eux parce qu'ils
sont occupés si tu sais tu sais c'est ça
ma lettre de riches etc c'est un
mal-être d'intellectuels et on réalité
lui a démontré de l'un vers ce qu'il
soit dit beaucoup d'agriculteurs et
souhaiter beaucoup de personnes de
milieux populaires à l'hôpital des
intellectuels aussi andré malraux alors
il a été aussi il a été aussi très
proche d'une certaine ce faire de
résistant gaulliste parce que lui-même
et avait été résistant pendant la guerre
et donc elle fait partie de ces réseaux
de résistance gaulliste donc il était
très proche d'andré malraux très proche
de romain gary c'est ce preneur à 13 ans
vous allez assister à l'investiture de
françois mitterrand ah oui parce que moi
j'étais curieuse de tout mais qu'est ce
qui vous y emmène mais vous savez que un
certain nombre de gaullistes ont voté à
gauche donc non ma fille tu mets dans ma
famille ça s'est déchiré déchiré à
l'élection de françois mitterrand y
avait ceux qui ont voté giscard et ceux
qui ont voté mitterrand donc les donc
les dîners était été enflammés et donc
moi j'avais 13 ans j'étais curieuse de
tout en plus évidemment comme on parlait
beaucoup de politiques à la maison je me
suis dit j'ai pris ma meilleure amie on
a traversé tout paris on était très en
vente à emporter on a oui à 13 ans et 13
ans pourquoi pas oui oui je 13 ans on
peut prendre le métro tout seul donc
quels souvenirs vous en avez gardé à
mais c'était extraordinaire c'était
impressionnant parce que c'était
moi j'ai senti de la force de stress de
mouvements d'alternance et l alternance
j'étais au premier rang le long de la
barricade et j'ai écouté l'hymne à la
joie avec ce président je connaissais
pas
alors inutile de vous dire j'ai été bien
déçu après bien bien déçus puisque je
n'ai jamais voté françois mitterrand il
n'y avait jamais voté à gauche j'ai voté
une fois à gauche
pour michel rocard aux européennes
ça devait être 89 quand j'étais tout
jeune c'était mon mouvement de révolte
[Musique]